let's talk about what we're doing to
white people
there's been something going on for a
while now that we're being told not to
notice
more to the point that we're asking
white people not only to ignore but to
accept the rising tide of racial hatred
against white people in the past decade
there has been a noticeable cultural
shift in what constitutes acceptable
speech as it relates to white people
back when I was a kid in the early 2000s
the mainstream American culture preached
about respecting each other's
differences and not seeing color
nowadays we say that not seeing color is
racism that you must see color
but the more I see how things are
unfolding the more I'm convinced that
this is wrong back then saying something
offhanded about why people were seen as
not appropriate just as it would be to
say something offhanded about people of
any other race
but that soon gave way to our current
times in which there exists virtually no
limit to what racial minorities can and
do say about white people I believe this
is the natural outgrowth of a perverse
ideology that teaches us that everything
every societal ill is the fault of white
people and that whatever Prejudice acts
we may inflict upon them does not
constitute discrimination because we
don't have the power to discriminate and
alarmingly this is particularly
pronounced in the younger generation but
is it true do we not have the power to
discriminate
well let's see this is not where I
thought this video was gonna go
where did you die what what did you
think it was going what are we doing to
white people and I was going to say
erasing them which I agree we are you
know with every interracial relationship
you know we white people we're
immigrating they're not having babies
we're erasing them oh that's where it's
gonna go we're not erasing them I
thought the Chinese guy was good hey man
you know what we do it we bring in our
people we take it over right and I was
going to celebrate it we was about to
celebrate it
get the future
[Music]
I love y'all you know what I'm saying
but it's like it is you know like y'all
don't have kids it is what it is like
what do you want me to say right okay
and then he went to where he went and I
I don't disagree because I feel like
this is stuff I've already said before I
I think I personally think it's super
cringe when some minorities get up on
these platforms and say everything is
white supremacy everything is white
people's fault and black people can't be
rocks you start can't discriminate or
even when they're doing punching Asian
dudes they say I hate y'all no no it's
not or it's not racism it's Prejudice
I'm like no that distinction is like no
no it wasn't great but it was sexual I'm
like okay thanks thanks stupid but it is
white people's fault what is everything
okay go for it hit him hit him with your
punchline well I got nothing it's just
that it feels good to say that you know
taking all your problems and be like
yeah there you go yeah you're wearing
that coat now yeah yeah there you go
the first time I've worn this court it's
cool
projects
oh shut your ass up
you know why I can't do it right because
if I start I can't stop
put that [__] out [__] put this [__] up
put this [__] on
I feel like my mom's putting me in a
prom dress all right
we have made a decision
they have replaced
with dabazulu the third the king of
Ethiopia we have come here today to
celebrate the crowning of a true king a
man who has come here kill the lion and
warn it afterwards
there you go I've come to these lands to
conquer the white women the women from
the caucus mountains to inform them
about what we are doing to white people
what are we doing to white people we are
giving them the daba they are going to
enjoy it eh it is not a sickness it is a
cure
hey yo yo how much you pay for this oh
and it was 2400 but we meet me what did
you just saying
I thought I was about to pay a few
hundred how much that's a few hundred
it's not it's not that I didn't pay for
it I didn't pay I didn't pay that much
okay I paid uh
1.8
I just want you guys to appreciate he
said that and I could appreciate I
respect as preach in my head all I kept
thinking was like bro I don't think I've
ever spelled over a hundred and
everything always got to be on sale this
is my mother but I respect it because
that's what I say you spent 1.8
but it was on sale but
there you go use that one point but that
[__] fly that [__] that [__] worth first
let's take a look at the racial hatred
at the interpersonal level in today's
society it has become somewhat
fashionable to think things and say
things about and to white people that
would not be acceptable if it was said
about any other race and we're being
taught that this double standard is not
wrong that it is rather a form of
empowerment they'll attribute negative
experiences that they've had with white
people to their whiteness you had an
argument in light at the grocery store
with a white person they were acting
entitled because they were white a white
driver cut you off while you were
driving they need to check their white
privilege your actions your conduct and
your existence in other words boil down
to your whiteness and ashamedly at one
point in time this was how I used to
think as well and Beyond the people in
my circle I noticed that many people of
color have this sort of blase attitude
an attitude most particularly pronounced
when there are no other white people
around things are being said not just
behind closed doors but out in the open
not just between close friends but
between complete strangers so here's the
thing this is something that I've
experienced countless times so I know
that there are other people who are
experiencing it too I know it must
resonate with at least some of you the
difficulty here is that no matter how
many anecdotes I share they are just
that anecdotes and people refuse to
believe that this is happening we'll
just chalk it up to my experiences being
a fluke or worse yet they'll say I'm
lying self-compiled some Tick Tock
videos I want you to take a look at the
things that are being said about white
people especially by the younger
generation the kind of statements people
wouldn't dare say about people of any
other race take a look at what is
stunningly in Vogue in today's society
and ask yourselves where does this lead
to years down the line you have a token
white and you're hanging out with your
friend group of color
you need to ask permission from
everybody in the group to bring your
white friend what the [__]
what
okay
like don't just bring them I might not
be in the mood to deal with white
shenanigans that day that's that's all
I'm saying and another thing it feeds
into their ego like don't don't let them
think they're a good white person
accomplices ask how can they support
black and indigenous people of color
and
sometimes I really don't know what to
say but here's one easy way
just don't have babies can
single-handedly cause the white genocide
that they are so afraid of with 2.25
billion Asian women and half a billion
white men baby it only take two
generations in two generations there
will no longer be any blonde haired
these are some things I noticed about
white American culture being grounded is
a punishment to them that's what they
call punishment
the least grounded least balanced most
destructive race
considers being grounded a punishment
yeah Tick Tock really is a breeding
ground for cringe
and the problem with that is that
algorithm the more you watch it the more
you get proposed that [__] yeah you see
a bunch of people saying dumb stuff and
spotting off out the side of their mouth
and getting millions of views on Tick
Tock encourages everybody else to do the
same and the algorithm really does feed
you right yeah like you thought content
creators on YouTube were lazy Tick Tock
got the laziest content creators I've
ever seen blowing up on nothing women
staring at the camera going
while some shitty ass song Let's play in
the background getting Millions girl
going like oh if he got a small dick and
get millions I'm like what but I guess
that's what people watch so what is with
Caucasian people and like their
inability to like read a [__] room
like y'all act like you don't understand
[__] because y'all be the first ones
during a conversation about the
Holocaust to get so mad when black
people be like you do realize that the
original Jewish people were black right
white people do not need to explain to
anybody about us all bleeding red
because baby you all are the people that
need to learn that lesson clearly
history shows that you all are the
people that like to pillage and
eradicate enslave and oppress attempt to
suppress greatness because you all
simply don't you went all the way to
Africa to physically take black people
from their homes shove them in on boats
where a lot of them got diseases and
died so the where they could sit on a
bus tell them which schools they could
go to which water fountains they could
use which bathrooms they could use and
that's sugar coating it those are just
turns I'm not even describing all the
disgusting things that happen and they
don't even want revenge they are letting
you guys skate by asking for equal
rights that's it
and you're still saying no
they are not as angry as they should be
y'all are getting off easy and you're
still saying no [__] you some people
look at that and chalk it up to the
grumblings of the powerless that's the
idea that when you have a party
disparity the less powerful sort of has
this General Society given leeway to
complain about the more powerful the
villagers complaining about their King
doesn't have the same ring as the king
making side include comments about the
villagers but that's not what's going on
here because although certain segments
of our society refuse to believe this
even as evidence mounted before our very
eyes in one side of the political aisle
people of color actually have greater
power than white people that's the truth
that is not being acknowledged by the
people that need to hear it because this
gets in the way of them wielding that
power in the way they won't malignantly
I've heard from somewhere that politics
is Downstream of culture and I think
that's certainly correct we have a
mainstream culture that tells us it's
okay to hold Prejudice and hateful view
of white people and our politics is then
infused with this energy and we see
active overt and on the books racial
discrimination of white people that
those who are perpetuating this hatred
is refusing to see as discrimination
they'll say no no no this is remediation
these are the same people who are making
tenuous arguments that some of our race
neutral laws discriminate against people
of color and this is certainly evidence
that in one side of the political aisle
people of color have more power than
white people because if we didn't have
the power we wouldn't be able to put
into place practices and Paul policies
that doesn't that's what power is things
like Minneapolis local government
agreeing to a contract with the teachers
union that says white teachers must be
fired first New York City's government
enacting a policy of having white
seniors go to the back of the line on
life-saving covered treatment a college
professor that says white people should
be killed and facing no repercussions
Cornell University Banning white people
from rock climbing lessons one of many
many instances of liberal colleges doing
the utmost to exclude and ostracize
white students by pop only events equal
no bro you need to stop looking at me
every time somebody says [__]
by pop
yeah yeah listen I think when it comes
to the whole idea of some of these laws
um yeah I think you have a very strong
argument there as far as like people
making comments and saying all this
stuff about white folks I wouldn't be
acceptable I agree which is why I think
everybody should be able to say
everything about everybody
that's why people say like white people
can't talk about black people like yes
they can go ahead I will never I know in
the society you gonna get ring your ass
but me personally I I'm like I ain't mad
at it what are we doing to white people
I don't know taking the skin and wearing
it
but what are we doing is you know what
I hate I hate this this new thing it
links to a lot of things right so I had
to I don't even know where to start and
maybe this is gonna be like usual when I
talk it's a bit all over the place
but there's a lot of things to unpack
right okay what are we doing to white
people what are we doing it's not so
much what we're doing to why people it's
just that I'm just gonna go for the for
the first point of what he said first
back then it was all about
I don't see color I don't see color and
it's just like the Matrix
the animatrix remember that [__] at
first it was okay
I don't see color that meant that but
what happened is
people started denying
the struggle that came with the color
like I know I don't see color but I also
don't see the struggle and the
difficulties that you can go through
yeah I like you I like you but yeah you
don't make the extra effort to so one
solution was kind of not enough and the
problem with that is where the problem
is from is whenever they dealt with
racism backed them and backed them in
the back then in the 90s and 80s
whatever they always try to do it in a
some kind of advertisement way with a
slogan with a catchphrase yeah I don't
see color the problem with that is
you're trying to emulate a whole ass
problem with just one catchphrase and
that never and people grab onto that and
it never solve the problem so whenever
you see yeah there's differences we have
to respect respect everybody back then
they were saying uh you don't you don't
see color or don't look at color it's
really just a catchphrase but it creates
other problems because it's it's a
problem that is so complex it comes from
different things in different places
that just solving it with a catchphrase
creates other [__] people back in the
80s and 90s they went the early 90s they
went on this bandwagon I don't see color
I don't see color sometimes when you
talk to old school people they still
have that hey but I don't see color yeah
well and then you meet new people like
no one's like no there's a problem with
that I gotta struggles we have
differences and I just want to be
respected as a human being which cause
other problems so that's where that is
from and that's
the slogan thing and never solves a
problem it's a shortcut to a bigger
issue I see color I like seeing color I
see color every day I don't mind it I
understand the sentiment the sentiment
from an individual says I don't see
colors this is the way I'm gonna treat
you as an individual which I think is
wonderful and that's great unfortunately
sometimes it's unconscious biases that
people are operating that you might need
to actually pay attention to within
yourself or maybe in other people and
that's where seeing color may be
important on the flip side there's
people who see color all day long and
that's all they see they don't see
shapes they don't see sizes they don't
see nothing you just see color that's
like [__] we know you see every
Spectrum okay can you see anything else
because that's not all people are
they're not just their skin tone so
there's a balance of those two things
which might sound like a boring answer
but it is the truth I don't walk through
life and say I don't see gender it's
stupid I go to the bathroom I see gender
when a woman can't do certain things a
man can't do I see gender when I'm
[__] I see gender
it is what it is when I'm watching
sports I see gender
I understand the concept of wanting to
see the individual for the individual
and I think that's a wonderful idea we
just I think the way sometimes this
slogan is employed like preach said is
it's almost to like disregard everything
which I think you can find a good
balance in between but like I said the
whole like
white people are to blame for everything
I just I personally think it's corny
what everyone who's just like you have
some people just everything white
supremacy white supremacy white
supremacy a patriarchy the patriarchy
the patriarchy and the reason why I find
this kind of messaging unappealing and I
think why this messaging is losing out
in public discourse is it removes
personal agency it removes personal
accountability it removes people's
ability to feel like they can influence
any kind of change in their own personal
life but I'm just not interested in
messaging that goes that far
so it really feels sometimes like yeah
sometimes they they just throw that out
there and
it's like they don't
pick themselves up no how many times you
do something yeah well how about you go
go for Grants well you know how it is
the way the system works nah but you
didn't try yeah but the way the system
works
bro just try to do it like that we'll go
through yeah but no it's not worth it
yeah you know and they have two [__]
shooting each other
white supremacy I'm white breath at
which point are any of you [__]
gonna take any accountability at which
point that you become an adult taking
decisions for yourself there's like no
balance between the messaging it's why
you see leftists being always about like
this fat acceptance thing and you have
right-wing conservative people who are
just like well there's nothing society
that makes people more likely to be fast
like no nothing in the food nothing in
the programming at school nothing in the
education nothing in the lack of access
to Good Foods in some areas no it's like
you can't have a balance for none of
these people I just I that's what I hate
about this discourse but anyways I feel
like we haven't even played this guy's
video so that's one at least give him a
chance so that's my thoughts but yeah
um if you guys want go check out the
rest of this video uh it seems pretty
well thought out whether you agree or
not so you guys can go check that out
but I just want to cover that let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below